[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre les travaux
de la haute assemblée on va parler cet
après-midi de logements puisque les
sénateurs ont auditionné emmanuelle
wargon la ministre du logement une
audition dans le cadre de l'examen du
budget 2011 22 alors la ministre a
présentés aux sénateurs le budget du
logement pour la dernière année de ce
quinquennat un budget en forte hausse
mais qui ne cache pas les mauvais
résultats du gouvernement en matière de
construction de logements je vous laisse
écouter l'audition des manuels varois
madame la ministre vous nous présenter
ce soir probablement le meilleur budget
logement du quinquennat
j'ai mis les arrange bien j'ai mis j'ai
mis des petites italique
[Rires]
c'est noël tous les jours dont celui là
c'est noël du logement aussi voilà les
moyens des trois programmes relatifs au
logement augmentent de 7,41 % en crédits
de paiement un peu plus même en
autorisations d'engagement 8% et donc
c'est ses programmes en crédits paiement
augmente de 16,3 milliards d'euros le
sénat est notre commission manquerait à
l'esprit d' équilibre qui caractérise
nos travaux si nous ne reconnaissions
pas le réel effort budgétaire accompli
et plusieurs points positifs le premier
est que à la différence des années
précédentes de budget ne vient pas
ponctionner action logement pour
financer les apn situent plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
puisqu'un accord a été conclu avec le
groupe paritaire pour sa réforme est en
faveur de la relance c'est donc l'état
qui abondera le fonds national d aide au
logement le final d'environ 640 millions
d'euros la seconde évolution majeure
porte sur l'hébergement d'urgence bien
sûr nous rapporte rur vous poseront des
questions
477 millions d'euros supplémentaires
sont débloqués c'est le résultat
effectivement de votre engagement
pendant la crise sanitaire pour mettre
un bris les personnes dans le besoin les
associations d'ailleurs saluer c'était
fort sans précédent qui a aussi montré
la capacité
notre capacité à prendre des mesures
contre le sans abrisme de même la
prévention des expulsions a fait l'objet
d'une priorité avec quelques
dispositions pour autant et mes
collègues auront certainement à coeur
d'y revenir pardonnez moi l'expression
une hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps
comme la fondation abbé pierre et
d'autres acteurs du secteur notre
commission dans le même esprit des clips
que j'évoquais à l'instant n'oublie pas
que c'est ce budget montre une réelle
inflexion il ne revient pas sur les
coups de canif passé dans le contrat
social contre les apl et le logement
social au travers de la rls où les
attaques contre action logement cela
paraîtra une chose mineurs mais l'an
passé nous avions rejeté un amendement
de notre commission portant sur dix
petits millions d'euros et visant à
garantir le financement du fonds
national d'accompagnement vers et dans
le logement qui normalement assurées par
les astreintes dalo a quitté par l'état
si finalement une fois de plus action
logement qui a accepté de payer cette
somme dans le cadre de la révision de
son plan d'investissement volontaire je
voudrais en nous de vous inviter avec
les réseaux de commissions sur deux
sujets qui nous tiennent à coeur la
construction neuve et la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne cher dominique
concernant la construction neuve notre
commission a alerté dès la sortie du
premier confinement sur la rive sur le
risque qu'à travers qu'après la risk la
crise sanitaire part dans ce succès de
la crise du logement notre commission a
également déploré que la construction
neuve est était je cite l'angle mort du
plan de relance le gouvernement semble
avoir pris partiellement la mesure de la
gravité de la situation la commission
rebsamen a formulé des propositions qui
pour certaines sont encourageantes ne
sont pas encore plus complètement
traduite dans le plf et pour d'autres
sont franchement inquiétante notamment
pour le sénat comme l'idée de
sanctionner les maires à l'exemple de la
loi sru qui ne serait pas assez allant
dans l'application de leur fait lâche
que souhaite faire le gouvernement sur
le sujet de nouvelles dispositions sont
l attente dans le cadre du plf du plfr
l'est peut-être nous parlerait vous de
la loi de traits 3d est que nous
évoquions à l'instant enfin comme l'an
passé je souhaiterais que vous nous
fassiez un point sur la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne il ya un an vous étiez
sur le point d'aller à marseille avant
l'audition blf et vous aviez convenu
avec nous que peu de choses avaient
changé depuis le président de la
république s'est rendu à marseille deux
fois
il veut obtenir des résultats et donc
vous nous direz vous peut nous en sommes
sur cet habitat a dit voilà madame les
mini jeux vous laisse le soin de
présenter votre budget réponde à ses
premières questions ensuite je donnerai
la parole à ou rapporteurs de la
commission dominique estrosi sassone
pour le logement à jean baptiste blanc
qui vous fait un retour dans la
commission des faits les affaires
économiques mais au titre voilà de son
nouveau titre de rapporteur spécial de
la commission des finances alain dufour
rapporteur pour avis la commission des
affaires sociales puis aux collègues qui
le souhaitent seront bien évidemment
j'invite chacun la brièveté non pas
comme moi puisque contenu de vos
contraintes d'agenda madame le ministre
votre audition ne durera qu'une heure
quinze et pour ma peine ma part
d'ailleurs je vous prie de m'en excuser
je serai obligé de partir au bout d'une
heure voilà mais je serai remplace yves
très avantageusement par dominique
madame la ministre
merci beaucoup madame la présidente je
vais dire quelques mots effectivement
présentation de mon budget et si vous le
souhaitez à la fin de cette présentation
je répondre à la question sur l'habitat
indigne sa chambre dans la présentation
j'avais évidemment prévu de parler de la
relance de la construction neuve donc
madame la présidente madame la
rapporteure pour avis monsieur le
rapporteur spécial mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je suis effectivement très
heureuse de vous présenter ce budget et
merci de l'appréciation générale dans
votre introduction madame la présidente
c'est effectivement je crois en un bon
budget pour le logement 2022 17,15
milliards d'euros de crédits soit une
augmentation de plus de 1 milliard
d'euros par rapport à l'année dernière
je mens réduit je m'en réjouis pardon et
à ces crédits s'ajoutent 2 milliards de
ma prime rénove qui ne sont pas dans les
crédits de la mission du logement mais
qui sont dans la mission transition
écologique sur le programme 174 plus les
13 5 milliards de dépenses fiscales du
secteur ce budget mme me semble
permettre de poursuivre et de conforter
les réformes engagées notamment en
matière de rénovation énergétique
d'hébergement et d'accès au logement et
donne à mon ministère des moyens
nouveaux pour soutenir le développement
d'une offre de logements abordables pour
commencer par l'hébergement ce plf
mobilise des moyens sans précédent pour
financer nos actions en faveur de
l'hébergement et de l'accès au logement
de nos concitoyens les plus fragiles et
pour soutenir des réformes structurelles
en cours le budget du programme 177
s'élève à 2,7 milliards d'euros sur 2022
c'est à dire une hausse de 50% en cinq
ans ce budget permet de poursuivre la
montée en puissance du plan logement
d'abord à ce jour plus de 300000
personnes sans domicile ont déjà été
accompagné vers le logement depuis 2018
c'est un résultat très important 305
milles exactement personnes qui étaient
à la rue ou essentiellement structures
d'hébergement et qui ont pu avoir accès
soir logement social soit une pension de
famille soit un logements en
intermédiation locative
ce qui fait en gros soixante mille
personnes par an et on espère plutôt
80000 personnes cette année donc c'est
très encourageant
pour amplifier cette dynamique nous
augmentons à l'intérieur du budget les
crédits liés au logement adapté en
hausse de 8% l'an prochain nous
continuons aussi à répondre aux urgences
en matière d'hébergement vous l'avez dit
madame la présidente 200 mille places
ont été maintenues ouvertes en 2021 le
seront jusqu'au printemps 2022 et nous
avons donné de la visibilité au secteur
avec une cible à 190 mille places
ouvertes fin 2022 c'est 40000 places de
plus en 2021 que l'année précédente
donc c'est un effort très important et
la petite diminution de 10 mille places
courant de l'année 2022 a vocation à
être couvertes précisément par l'accès
au logement dans les différentes formes
de logement d'abord logement social ou
autre
sur la partie hébergement
juste un mot pour dire que nous
travaillons maintenant que les
associations sur une programmation à
moyen terme c'est-à-dire une promo un
pilotage plus structurelle de ces
crédits qui était jusqu'à présent
piloter énormément stop and go pour
donner de la visibilité aux associations
essayer de retravailler le
l'équilibré entre les besoins et l'offre
notamment qualitativement pour des
places potentiellement plus pour des
femmes isolées ou pour des familles en
fonction de la situation des
départements et donc pour pouvoir
s'engager dans une trajectoire plus
qualitatif sur la rénovation énergétique
c'est également une priorité importante
donc c'est les crédits portent
essentiellement sur ma prime rénove qui
nous permettront d'accompagner cette
année entre 700 milles et 800 mille
logements qui font l'objet d'une demande
ma prime rénovant 2021 pour 2022 nous
maintenons un financement à 2 milliards
d'euros avec un énorme effort de
rebasage 1 milliard d'euros bas âge
puisque comme vous avez en 2021 les
crédits sont essentiellement financé sur
le plan de relance et du coup les
crédits rentrer maintenant en base
budgétaire
pour accompagner ce changement le
plafond d'emplois de l'anah augmente de
30 3 e tp et les effectifs de l'anah on
était presque doublé en trois ans
nous finançons également le reste à
charge à travers la prolongation de
l'éco prêt à taux zéro jusqu'à fin 2023
et une amélioration de cet éco-prêt
notamment avec le cumul avec ma prime
rénove un amendement sera déposé a été
même déposé à l'assemblée sur ce sujet
au delà de la main prime rénove nous
mobilisons beaucoup de moyens en faveur
de la rénovation des logements et de
l'amélioration du cadre de vie je pense
à toutes les interventions de l'âne à
habiter mieux sérénité le plan
initiative copropriété l'adaptation des
logements au vieillissement et à la
perte d'autonomie
en trois ans il est intéressant de noter
que le niveau des engagements de l'anah
en dehors de ma prime rénove or a
augmenté de 50% donc l'anah n'est pas
mobilisée que pour l'imprimerie offre
même si elle est qu'elle est au rendez
vous mais aussi pour le reste nous avons
par ailleurs l'augmentation constante
des moyens consacrés à la rénovation
urbaine puisque nous aurons doubler le
budget du npd rue sur la durée du
quinquennat avec deux milliards
supplémentaires
présentés cette année pour passer de 10
milliards à 12 milliards et la
réhabilitation énergétique des logements
sociaux avec 500 millions d'euros qui
seront à peu près tous engagés d'ici la
fin de l'année 2021
enfin cette loi de finances nous permet
de continuer à soutenir l'offre de
logements abordables donc d'abord elle
continue à financer les aides
personnelles au logement
13,1 milliards d'euros de financements
des appels en 2022 soit une augmentation
de 650 millions par rapport à 2021 et
pas de fonction sur action logement
comme vous l'avez signalé ensuite sur la
construction neuve nous avons tiré les
conséquences de la commission rebsamen
en reprenant en plf une bonne partie des
propositions qui ont été faites la plus
structurante étant probablement la
compensation intégrale de l'exonération
de taxes ce foncière sur les propriétés
bâties pendant 10 ans pour les logements
sociaux à grethen 2021 amis 2026 qui a
été introduite par amendement à
l'assemblée mais également un soutien
accru aux logements intermédiaires
financé par les institutionnels avec là
aussi une transformation de
l'exonération de tfpb en 1 une créance
d'impôt à la charge de l'état qui
arrivent par amendement à l'assemblée
nationale et la mobilisation de 175
millions de france relance pour
accompagner des contrats de relance du
logement conclue dans les prochains mois
entre l'état et les collectivités en
particulier dans les territoires tendue
et le gouvernement soutiendra également
des amendements à l'assemblée nationale
je crois qu'il ya un écho
pour prolonger le prêt à taux zéro
prolonger le dispositif censi bouvard
prolonger le de normandie dans l'ancien
et prolonger l'expérimentation du zonage
pinel en bretagne je signale aussi que
le fonds friche est passé 300 millions à
650 millions cette année nous sommes en
train de faire les remontées avec les
préfets pour reconnaître les lauréats de
la deuxième édition et nous avons
annoncé un engagement à sa pérennisation
tout ceci nous permet en parallèle de
soutenir la construction de logement
social avec un milliard cinq des dalles
à pierre mobilisés pour 250 mille
logements sociaux en deux ans 120 milles
comme objectif cette année et 120 villes
seront difficiles à atteindre mais on
sera entre 100000 et 110 milles et la
mobilisation continue enfin nous
continuons à soutenir l'accession à la
propriété
outre la prolongation du prêt à taux
zéro nous avons soutenu fortement le
déploiement du bail réel solidaire vingt
mille logements brs devrait être
commercialisé d'ici fin 2020 4 et action
logement dans le cadre du partenariat
renouvelé distribuer dans le cadre de
l'avenant relance des primes accession
de 10000 euros à destination des
salariés la dernière réforme en cours et
celle du dispositif fiscal ou et
abordable un amendement arrive à
l'assemblée nationale pour le simplifier
pour le rendre plus intéressant pour les
propriétaires passant d'un abattement
une réduction d'impôts dont les taux
sont ajustés à la réalité des taux
marginaux d'imposition et à partir de
loyers qui sont calculés à partir des
loyers réels et pas de loyer théorique
je pense que ce dispositif peut trouver
son public beaucoup plus facilement une
fois que cette réforme aura eu lieu donc
vous voyez pas mal pas mal de nouveautés
sur le budget logement en ce qui
concerne la commission rebsamen pour le
reste beaucoup de propositions sont des
propositions réglementaires notamment
dans l'accélération des contentieux de
la traite du traitement des contentieux
et dans des simplification du droit de
l'urbanisme
aucune disposition coercitive
supplémentaire vis à vis des communes
n'est prévue par le gouvernement suite à
ce rapport revanche que nous irons bien
débattre de la loi sru dans le cadre de
la loi 3ds à l'assemblée nationale suite
aux débats qui avaient eu lieu au sénat
et en ce qui concerne la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne peut-être pour finir
en répondant directement votre question
madame la présidente
nous continuons d'un côté investir sur
le plan initiative copropriété qui est
un plan significatif qui marche plutôt
bien nous continuons aussi à soutenir
les orcs codienne en région parisienne
mais également aux montants 1h caudines
anime la continuité ce que nous avons
fait à marseille les travaux avancent
plutôt bien le soutien de l'anah à la
métropole en matière de lutte contre
l'habitat indigne a doublé en trois ans
de 16 millions en 2019 à 28 millions
d'euros en 2021 l'état continue à
cofinancer le relogement des ménages à
travers l'accompagnement social de ce
qui s'appelle la mousse leur logement
que nous continuerons jusqu'à fin 2022
l'anru continue à financer des actions
de recyclage urbain déjà 500 logements
ont été rénovés soit 30 bâtiments est la
société de projet la sp la hyène est
maintenant opérationnelle avec un
directeur général une feuille de route
qui a été adoptée en juillet dernier et
le prévoit de rénover quatre îlots
prioritaires qui couvre en gros deux
mille logements avec un démarrage dès le
premier semestre 2010 22 donc le
partenariat opérationnel à marseille
progresse relativement vite même si
suffisamment à l'échelle de la ville ça
reste significatif et que nous avons
aussi des copropriétés dégradées des
quartiers nord de marseille un traité
très bien merci merci madame la ministre
j'entends votre discours qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont en train
d'être fait à l'assemblée nationale par
voie d'amendement c'est quand même assez
déstabilisant pour le parlement pour
travailler
sur les crédits il n'ya pas évidemment
le président barroso chant fiscalité je
reconnais tout à fait qu'un certain
nombre d'améliorations sont en train de
passer par amendement les articles non
rattachés passant à l'assemblée
nationale cette semaine et donc
effectivement ça ça arrive maintenant
voilà
madame la rapporteur dominique estrosi
sassone
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre donc j'ai bien évidemment un
certain nombre de questions à vous poser
elles sont assez précise la première est
relative aux apl puisque vous avez mis
en oeuvre cette année enfin la réforme
du calcul des apl pour tenir compte des
revenus contemporain vous avez procédé
c'est vrai à certains ajustements en
particulier pour les étudiants et pour
les jeunes en contrats de
professionnalisation
pour autant des associations dont l'une
âge font état de difficultés
persistantes pour les moins de 25 ans
les jeunes actifs en situation précaire
entrants sur le marché du travail et
demande des ajustements complémentaires
je voudrais savoir ce que vous en pensez
qu est ce que vous entendez répondre à
l'association lui nage par rapport à ces
publics qui semble ne veux pas avoir été
prise en compte même si effectivement un
certain nombre d'ajustements ont été
faits ma deuxième question porte sur
l'hébergement d'urgence le budget 2022
s'annonce effectivement historique par
son montant et par son ambition mais la
gestion sous enveloppe fermée de ce
programme programme pardon était
vraiment réaliste on le sait c'est une
dépense de guichet en bout de chaîne
d'autant plus que l'accueil est par
principe
inconditionnels vous envisagé de fermer
dix mille places en 2022 est ce
seulement possible au regard de la
pression migratoire que nous connaissons
calais en est par exemple un bon exemple
ou des demandes non satisfaites que les
associations évaluent aujourd'hui entre
5000 et 10 toujours sur le programme 177
pouvez vous nous indiquer pourquoi le
fonds d'indemnisation des bailleurs
acquis et refuser l'expulsion avec le
concours de la force publique n'a pas
été transféré au ministère de
l'intérieur dans le programme 216 du
ministère de l'intérieur au ministère du
logement comme vous l'aviez souhaitait
enfin je voudrais vous interroger sur un
certain nombre d'autres points qui ne
figure pas encore dans le plf ou qui
sont amenés à y figurer par voie
d'amendement il ya d'abord la création
de ma prime adapte que vous avez annoncé
pour financer les travaux d'adaptation
du logement au vieillissement qu'en est
il la transformation de l'exonération de
tfpb dont bénéficie le logement
intermédiaires en crédits d'impôt promis
par le premier ministre vous nous dites
que ça arrive par voie d'amendements à
l'assemblée nationale et les modalités
de récupération de la surcompensation
hlm donc sur tous ces sujets ou en tout
cas sur au moins deux d'entre eux
puisque sur l'exonération de tfpb vos
logements intermédiaires dont on sait
qu'il ya un amendement où en sont les
discussions et il y aura t'il de
nouveaux amendements dans tlf ou plus
tard enfin les acteurs du logement
social souhaiterait deux évolutions à la
marge de la rls
l'exclusion des ménages ne touchant pas
les apl mais bénéficiant de la rls
et la différence de traitement au sein
des résidences universitaires c'est très
précis entre celles qui sont gérées par
un bailleur social est soumise à la rs
et celles qui ne le sont pas sera-t-il
possible d'aboutir dans ce projet de loi
sur ces sujets plus particulièrement où
sera renvoyé après la présidentielle et
même si c'est pas l'objet de cette
audition puisqu'on est là pour vous
entendre sur votre budget comme l'a fait
là la présidente je peux vous dire
simplement notre inquiétude enfin mon
inquiétude mais je crois partagée ici
par bon nombre de mes collègues sur les
déclarations que nous avions entendu
al'approche de l'examen de la loi de 3ds
à l'assemblée nationale que ce soit les
déclarations du rapporteur michael nogal
que ce soit vos propres déclarations
madame la ministre que ce soit la
déclaration de la présidente de l' us h
madame cos nous sommes inquiets parce
que nous avons le sentiment que tout le
travail qui a été fait ici un travail
sérieux appuyé sur un rapport fait avec
ma collègue valérie d'état que nous
avons largement partagé avec vous dans
différentes réunions et avec la ministre
gouro tout ce travail sur la réforme de
la loi sru que nous avons voté ici au
sénat et qui je voue la sueur sur les
territoires a été particulièrement
appréciée nous avons l'impression que
vous avez la volonté l'intention de
détricoter tout ce que nous avons fait
ici à travers des déclarations qui
portent sur le fait que vous voulez
rétablir toutes les sanctions alors que
c'est une vision un petit peu
caricatural le travail que nous avons
fait parce que nous avons pas supprimer
toutes les sanctions nous avons supprimé
un certain nombre de sanctions que nous
avons considéré que la cour des comptes
a jugé
contreproductive et inefficace mais nous
avons gardé des sanctions nous avons
voulu aussi par exemple sur dire qu'on
va remettre on va revenir sur les
communes qui ont plus de 40 % de
logements sociaux sur lesquels nous
disons oui il faut continuer à
construire et compris du logement social
mais plus de logement social
d'intégration du pays aujourd'hui on
entendu des déclarations qui veulent
revenir sur ce point donc voilà on est
on est inquiet alors on attend les des
barbapapas préjugés et débats qui vont
avoir lieu à l'assemblée nationale mais
sachez qu'ici nous serons
particulièrement vigilants au vu du
travail que nous avons essayé de faire
sans dogmatisme sans idéologie mais pour
répondre aux attentes et aux besoins des
territoires dans leur spécificité
pourtant ça aurait été facile de le
faire jean baptiste blanc monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur anne qui est pas n du tout
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre ya mes chers collègues nous
donner la parole cet après midi
je partagerai les inquiétudes ma
collègue dominique ça sonne estrosi est
l'occasion de présenter mon rapport
mardi prochain devant la commission des
finances
sur cette émission cohésion des
territoires simplement trois questions à
mon tour dont une déjà exprimé au
minimum la frappe la première concernant
le dispositif pinel la seconde
concernant les aides à la pierre et
enfin concernant les objectifs de
construction
des logements en tout cas désagréments
de logements sociaux donc d'abord le
dispositif pinel vous avez annoncé
madame la ministre est de maintenir
l'accès ce dispositif a tout plein en
2023 pour des logements respectant
certains critères de qualité mais cet
élargissement
ne semble avoir qu'une portée limitée
puisque le dispositif pinel doit en
l'état du droit s'arrêter au 31 décembre
2000 24 votre intention n'est elle pas
plutôt que me l'a proposé l'inspection
générale des finances de favoriser le
retour des institutionnels dans le
logement intermédiaire et le
remplacement de l'exonération de tfpb
par un crédit d'impôt pour les
institutionnels et qui a été aussi
avancé irait dans ce sens la deuxième
question c'est celle des aides à la
pierre qui sont financés en majeure
partie comme on le sait depuis 2020 par
action logement et qui a pris le relais
des bailleurs sociaux
atteint notamment par la rls comme on
l'a dit et redit si hors cette
contribution est prévu jusqu'en 2022
seulement
action logement dont j'ai reçu les
représentants en audition ne semble plus
avoir de marge suffisante pour la
prolonger par suite et il n'y a pas de
raison pour que les organismes de
logements trouve des ressources
nouvelles d'ici là quel doit être le
financement du fonds national d'aidé à
la pierre après 2022 c'est ma question
et enfin l'objectif
de construction de 250 milles à
l'agrément de logements sociaux en 2021
et 2022 mais les auditions que j'ai
menées dans le cadre de la loi de
finances ne font penser que cet objectif
sera bien difficile à tenir quel est
votre prévision d'agrément de logements
sociaux en 2021 nous avons entendu des
prévisions tournant autour de 100 mille
vous le confirmer cent mille cinq cent
mille seulement pourrions-nous dire
malgré l'effet de rattrapage des projets
non réalisés pendant la crise sanitaire
jeu pro merci même la présidente si jean
baptiste et enfin alain dufourcq voilà
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires sociales
chers collègues vous pouvez enlever
votre masse pour parler dans le micro à
l'asra pur effet madame le président mam
le ministre merci droit ministre
remercie de me donner la parole
je salue d'abord les efforts qui ont été
faits dans sur le budget le programme
517 pour 2022 est justement l'effet de
ne pas programmer une loi de finances
rectificative
néanmoins ce qui concerne le
maintiennent le niveau des places
d'hébergement généralistes pour de 5000
places en 2022 jusqu'au mois de mars
combien tofan d'accélérer les nuitées
hôtelières et d'améliorer surtout après
avoir entendu les diverses associations
d'améliorer la qualité or est-ce que
vous pouvez mam le ministre nous
indiquer quelles sont les
transformations de ses nuitées en place
de ch et crs jour merci merci mes amis
je vous propose de répondre à ça c'est
déjà pas mal de questions et ensuite je
donne à la parole à mes collègues
merci beaucoup effectivement pas mal de
questions donc la première sur les apl
et les jeunes donc vous l'avez dit
madame la sénatrice et une réforme qui
était attendu qu'on a mené à bien qu'on
appelle appel en temps réel pour essayer
d'éviter de prononcer le mot contemporai
anisation et qui finalement s'est passé
dans des conditions techniques
satisfaisantes et finalement dans des
conditions d'acceptabilité je pense
globalement satisfaisante ça consiste à
ne pas changer le barème des aides mais
à prendre en compte les dernières
ressources connues reste la question des
jeunes pour les jeunes la question des
étudiants et traiter les étudiants à
partir moment ils ont un statut étudiant
voient leur apl maintenu après comme
avant la question des jeunes en
apprentissage ou en contrat de
professionnalisation et traiter les
apprentis avaient un abattement sur
leurs ressources qui font qu'ils gardent
les appels à taux plein temps qu'ils
sont apprentis les jeunes en région nous
les moins jeunes d'ailleurs en contrat
de professionnalisation n'était pas dans
la même situation on a rectifié ça on a
rectifié de façon rétroactive et
paiements rétroactifs au lieu à partir
de septembre dernier il reste un cas de
figure qui est consubstantielle à la
réforme qui est les jeunes qui rentrent
dans la vie active et qui ont leur
première ressource est par définition
quand on prend les dernières ressources
connues on prend les premières
ressources donc les appels sont moins
favorables dans ce système que dans le
système précédent d'une certaine manière
le maintien pendant deux ans des appels
étaient une forme d' aide à l'entrée
dans la vie active qui était d'une
certaine manière assez injuste parce que
ça dépend des de votre historique propre
aux apl c'est à dire que pour deux
jeunes prenant un job prenant leur
premier emploi s'il avait été aux apl
comme étudiant y maintenaient à une app
elle à taux plein supérieurs à ce qu'ils
avaient comme apple en tant qu'étudiant
pendant deux ans s'il n'avait jamais été
aux apl il était en évaluation
forfaitaire avec un mode de calcul plus
défavorable qu'aujourd'hui donc
maintenant on a un système un mode de
calcul qui est unifiée qui est clair
action logement a mis en place une
nouvelle aide qui s'appelle mon job mon
logement de 1000 euros qui est une
espèce de coup de pouce pour les jeunes
qui rentrent dans la vie active dans ce
cas précis on considère collectivement
qu'il faut aider les jeunes qui rentrent
dans la vie active c'est pas forcément
par les apl qu'il faut le faire mais en
tout cas c'est la population pour
laquelle effectivement la situation est
moins favorable après qu'avant mais
c'était une espèce de situation qui
s'était installé encore une fois avec
des cheminements individuelles qui sont
très différents d'un jeune à l'autre
pour la question sur l'hébergement
d'urgence
oui c'est difficile de gérer sous
enveloppe fermée même si on a maintenant
une enveloppe à un niveau élevé et
probablement que nous aurons besoin
d'essayer de gérer l'offre de base qu'on
va essayer de transformer
qualitativement de nuitées hôtelières
vers des chu chrs et amélioration de la
prise en charge qui est la vocation à
rester sous enveloppe fermée et
continuer à avoir la possibilité de
déployer des moyens exceptionnels face à
des situations exceptionnelles parce que
il ya des cas dans lesquels c'est
difficile d'anticiper donc il faut que
nous apprenions ce qui le tage en tout
cas pour la base on enveloppe fermée
peut-être avec dans des cas particuliers
des prises en charges exceptionnelles
inversement c'est assez simple ce
programme budgétaire ne soit plus du
tout géré en crédits évaluatif c'est à
dire on ouvre on sait qu'on n'a pas
assez et on compense ou pas en fin
d'année on a quand même trouvé une
situation mais collectivement parce que
ça fait longtemps que c'est comme ça
dans laquelle ce sont les associations
qui faisait la trésorerie parce qu on
n'ouvrait jamais assez donc on ouvrait
peu en début d'année on ouvrait un peu
en collectif budget les associations
avaient six mois d'arriérés de paiement
du financement de la prise en charge des
places quand on est dans cette situation
là c'est assez difficile de discuter
qualité avec les associations qualité de
la prise en charge évolution évolution
de l'offre le fait de contractualiser à
niveau élevé si on arrive à relancer
l'offre de logements à la fois la
construction de logements sociaux et
l'intermédiation locative et l'offre
loup et abordable ça doit nous permettre
d'avoir une offre suffisante qui permet
d'avoir des sorties vers le haut et donc
de considérer que deux cent mille ou
cent quatre-vingt-dix mille places c'est
en gros le bun étiage sur le fond
d'indemnisation des bailleurs du
programme 216 ce qu'on a fait c'est au
1er janvier 2021 nous avons transféré la
gestion du programme 177 al hadi al qui
a été un gros travail de transfert et
j'en profite pour saluer la dial qui est
extrêmement mobilisés là dessus on n'est
pas prêt pour le transfert du programme
216 donc la question est toujours
ouverte mais elle ne se fera pas au 1er
janvier prochain l'important c'est
surtout que ces crédits soient mobilisés
nous nous sensibilisons les préfets sur
le fait que quand les expulsions n'ont
pas lieu fait plus précisément que le
concours de la force publique n'est pas
octroyé y compris pour des bonnes
raisons il faut généraliser
l'indemnisation des propriétaires et on
a rajouté des crédits sur le programme
de 116 pour ça
m'a pris m'adapte c'est probablement le
nom d'une prochaine aide mais rien n'est
encore arbitré le premier ministre m'a
confié une mission ainsi qu'à mes
collègues sophie cluzel et brigitte
bourguignon pour y travailler en octobre
dans un premier temps l'idée est de
d'harmoniser tous les critères
d'octroi des aides qui sont dans
certains cas versé par l'anah dans
d'autres jusqu'à présent par action
logement et par la cnav et d'aller
probablement vers une nouvelle aide très
probablement avec l' architecture posée
début 2022 mais probablement pas de mise
en oeuvre opérationnelle dans cette
mandature
sur la con la compensation enfin sur la
fin de l'exonération de la taxe sur les
propriétés bâties pour le logement
intermédiaire et la compensation par un
crédit d'impôt bas l'amendement arrive
incessamment à l'assemblée nationale sur
la surcompensation
moi j'ai souhaité relancer les travaux
que les organismes hlm pour que nous
puissions aller au bout des discussions
sur les critères la méthode et le
démarrage de 2 tu contrôles de la
surcompensation parlant kohl's il avait
initialement été envisagé un rendement
en 2022 donc un article plf finalement
nous n'envisageons pas de rendement
budgétaire en 2022 l'idée de trouver de
façon consensuelle le mode de calcul la
méthode qui nous permet d'avancer vous
de voir avec les organismes hlm quelle
est la période de référence sur laquelle
les premiers contrôles vont avoir lieu
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
cet article a été retiré du plf il avait
été envisagé sur les évolutions à la
marche de la rls ça ne sera pas pour le
1er janvier 2022 ni l'une ni l'autre sur
rls pour les ménages qui ne sont pas
bénéficiaires des appels on est en train
de regarder mais c'est en fait
relativement compliquée et sur une
inéquité dans les résidences
universitaires là pour le coup c'est un
sujet vous nous avez signalé récemment
je sais pas si on a réellement un
problème in fine et puisque quand il ya
rls il ya justement des appels et vice
versa mais moi je suis prête à
l'instruire simplement en tout cas ce
sera pas pour le 1er janvier prochain
sur ce que vous disiez sur la loi 3ds
moi je reconnais travail qui a été fait
au sénat que évidemment dont nous avons
très souvent discutée en séance et en
dehors c'est pas un mystère de dire que
nous nous souhaitons revenir aux
sanctions telles qu'elles étaient
initialement prévues dans le projet de
loi du gouvernement et je crois l'avoir
dit a très souvent en séance donc sur la
partie sanction c'est vrai que toutes
les sanctions n'ont pas été supprimés
mais un certain nombre ont été supprimés
ou ou limitées et
la volonté du gouvernement c'est plutôt
de revenir à l'équilibré du texte sur
les sanctions en ce qui concerne le
plafonnement à 40% et pl a hissé de
toute façon conforme à ce que nous avons
signé par circulaire nadia et moi il y a
quelques mois aux préfets et donc la
discussion est très ouverte sur ce point
là
ensuite sur le pinel plus
le choix de ce gouvernement a été de
prolonger un certain de dispositifs
fiscaux pour donner de la visibilité au
secteur de l'immobilier mais pas
forcément de se prononcer sur leur
avenir à moyen long terme et ça je pense
que c'est un sujet du du début du
prochain quinquennat pour président
gouvernement majorité qui sortiront des
urnes donc le pin elle est prolongée
jusqu'à fin 2000 24 avec une
décroissance des taux connu par les
acteurs et autres cas le gouvernement ne
s'est pas prononcé sur l'opportunité de
maintenir ou pas et sur l' équilibre qui
est une vraie question entre le soutien
au logement intermédiaire fait part des
institutionnels à travers l'outil
logements intermédiaires et le soutien
au logement intermédiaire à travers
l'investissement des particuliers à
travers le dispositif pinel et s qui on
a besoin des deux compartiments comment
est ce qu il s'équilibre donc ça c'est
une question qui est pauvre a priori
pour la prochaine mandature en attendant
le décret pinel plus ce sera bientôt
soumis à concertation et son objectif
est simplement d'appliquer la loi de
finances de l'année dernière en disant
que pour
dans des cas dans lesquels des critères
de qualité intrinsèque et des critères
environnementaux supérieur à la à la
norme sont atteints dans ce cas là le
pin elle est maintenue à taux plein mais
ça n'ira pas plus loin et c'est
applicable aux années 2023 2024 et ça ne
préjuge pas de la décision qui sera
prise par la suite sur l'évolution des
aides et vous connaissez les rapports et
l'inspection générale des finances
notamment
sur l'efficacité ou pas des dispositifs
de soutien à l'investissement des
particuliers c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle je pense que louer abordable
peut être un dispositif est intéressant
parce que là il soutient pas la
construction mais la mise sur le marché
de logements à prix abordable il peut
être complémentaire sur les aides à la
pierre c'est un peu la même réponse
elles sont prévues comme ça à financer
par action logement jusqu'à fin 2022
après et la rls est également prévue
jusqu'à fin 2022 donc on a une clause de
revoyure général en 2022 pour le budget
2023 qui va avec la convention
quinquennale 2023 2027 d'action logement
qui sera à négocier il y aura du travail
pour le prochain ou la prochaine
ministre du logement quelle que soit sa
personnalité pour les 250 milles oui
c'est difficile à atteindre je voulais
pas caché je les dis dans mon
introduction
moi mon hypothèse d'atterrissage et
probablement entre 105 me laissant dix
mille aujourd'hui on refait un comité de
pilotage dans dix jours
j'espère qu'on sera au-dessus de 105000
donc je pense qu'on sera probablement
dans cette fourchette c'est à dire en
dessous des 120 mille prévus mais quand
même très au dessus des 87 milles de
l'année dernière et objectivement c'est
plutôt un bon résultat parce que si on
était simplement à faire du rattrapage
par rapport aux opérations n'ont fait
l'année dernière tout irait bien mais en
réalité on a une vraie difficulté
intrinsèque à faire sortir des projets
de logements sociaux et je pense que si
nous n'avions pas lancé une mobilisation
très forte très volontariste on n'aurait
pas atteint ces chiffres qui nous ramène
à ce qu'on faisait précédemment et qui
j'espère continuerons avec une dynamique
qui sera peut-être meilleur en 2022 par
rapport à 2021
et enfin votre question sur la
transformation des places je pense y
avoir en partie répondu effectivement
maintenant qu'on a on a une enveloppe
avec une visibilité les associations
demandent une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle sur l'hébergement jeu le
gouvernement n'a pas pris d'engagement
sur une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle en revanche sur le fait de
travailler la programmation façon
pluriannuelle pour que les préfets
puissent donner des indications dans la
durée aux associations qui gèrent des
places même si on ça n'est pas adossé
une loi de programmation que ça doit
être ensuite revalider par le budget
global en plf ça je pense que c'est
atteignable donc seconde travaux que
nous avons lancés y compris ce que je
vous disais en essayant de faire une
analyse qualitative de 2 quelle place on
a besoin est ce qu'on a besoin de plus
de places d'hébergement est ce qu'on
peut on transformer plus vers des
résidences sociales ou du logement
accompagner est-ce que les besoins des
femmes victimes de violence des
sortantes de maternité malheureusement
parce qu'on en a marre tu riante avec
bébé sont couverts est-ce que les
besoins des familles sont couverts et
donc comment on fait pour ne pas
seulement gérer un contingent de places
mais gérer aussi une adaptation de
l'offre par rapport à la réalité du
besoin et après bien sûr tout ceci est
aussi dépendant de l'attractivité du
territoire pour les personnes qui ne
sont pas les résidents nationaux et ça
c'est forcément difficile à évaluer
merci madame la ministre marie noëlle
lienemann ensuite viviane artigalas
premières questions concernant
l'accession sociale à la propriété
si vous a pas échappé que la fameuse
prime qu'elle a été créée par action
logement est une prime qui va déjà être
consommée quasiment dans les mois qui
viennent comme ça va très vite donc ça
prouve une grande appétence et un besoin
d'accession de asocial est ce que vous
envisagez de faut négocier avec l'accès
au logement la prolongation il vient il
faut mettre un budget de l'état une
prime équivalente pour peut-être un
public pas simplement de l'un des
salariés est peut-être en ciblant
davantage sur deux du groupe et de
l'individuel groupé ou du collectif en
tout cas il ya une demande d'autant plus
qu'on a plus
la paix à l'accession donc il ya une
vraie attente de ce côté là il ya au
toujours l'éternel sujet tout j'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre pourquoi ça
pose problème de la différence de
taxation entre les aurais fesses quand
elles sont portées par les les bailleurs
sociaux qui ne payent pas les fesses
liesse parce qu'elles sont assiégées
mais les mêmes joseph s quand ils ne
sont pas ces demandes ailleurs sociale
par exemple à une coopérative avec des
collectivités locales et des organismes
bailleurs sociaux ps alors quels sont
les sujets sur les mêmes missions elles
fassent pas de dividende donc je
n'arrive toujours pas à comprendre
pourquoi on n'obtient pas la même le
même allègement de liesse pour ce qui
est la commission rebsamen il est prévu
dans cette commission de faire des
contrats locaux avec les
intercommunalités
pour ma part j'ai insisté pour que les
communes soient éventuellement soit
sûrement signataire d'un contrat de
relance du logement et dans les
propositions il est prévu de revoir les
critères des aides des maires bâtisseurs
est ce que vous savez sur ce point à
point de vue est ce que vous pensez
lancer ces contrats au delà du plan de
relance est ce que c'est les même pas
les mêmes je crois qu'il ya une grande
attente je pense de ce côté là enfin
beaucoup de questions ont été posées sur
la rls j'y reviens pas ont nourri le
débat sur la caisse de compensation
certains collègues l'ont évoqué je
voudrais insister sur la surcompensation
pour l'accession à la propriété la vente
est l'accession aucune simulation mais
qu'il fait parlants coche pour les
opérations d'accession thierry prat kull
la surcompensation que produits locatifs
ça a été expérimenté que pour le locatif
ont leur mode de calcul ça q
complètement les organismes qui font
d'accession sociale
à la propriété et donc non seulement
faut se mettre d'accord mais là je pense
qu'il faut une expérimentation et un
report qu'en pensez vous madame la
ministre
merci marie noëlle viviane artigalas
ensuite daniel salmon merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre moi je
voudrais aussi revenir sur la réforme
des apl effectivement quand vous dites
que techniquement ça s'est bien passé je
suis désolée elle a été reportée parce
que les caf n'arrivait pas à assumer
cette réforme et on sait très bien
qu'elle a été difficile vous avez encore
c'est une étude des factions mais
uniquement sur les gains financiers que
vous pouviez faire avec cette réforme
moi je voudrais savoir si vous êtes
maintenant capable de nous donner une
évaluation précise venant de votre
ministère sur les grands perdants de
cette réforme est ce que vous comptez
faire pour y remédier et vous en avez
déjà me parler sur les l'engagement de
pour les cinq mille deux cent cinquante
mille logements logement je pense que là
aussi vous devez revoir vos prévisions à
la baisse effectivement c'est difficile
à attraper la construction l on sait
bien qu'elle a été mise à mal par la rls
la construction de logements donc il est
bien difficile de rattraper cela s'est
un peu tardive mais c'est là on a menés
là je croise en 1 mil loge l'agrément de
logements maintenant à ce jour
je donc il faut revoir ce la baisse mais
je crois aussi qu'il y a un autre souci
que sur la construction que vous qu'on
n'a pas bien mesuré la prob pauvreté
augmente dans notre dans notre pays est
grandement et les besoins de logements
très sociaux se fonderait sur jean et
dans certains quartiers politique de la
ville les des municipalités se sont
engagés dans des parcours résidentiels
et donc ils libèrent des logements
sociaux or tout ça pour avoir une forme
de mixité sociale d'aller vers de la
mixité sociale donc et éviter d'avoir à
remettre dans ces quartiers politique de
la ville trop de personnes en situation
de pauvreté ou d'extrême pauvreté or
comme un manque de logements dans les
attributions de logements ces logements
libérés sont finalement on revient sur
un cercle vicieux où ces quartiers
politique de la ville on avait où on
avoue on essayait de ne pas remettre
delà des situations des personnes en
situation de pauvreté qu'il revienne
comment comptez vous faire pour essayer
de résoudre ce problème est la dernière
question c'est sûr voilà la poule à vous
nous avez parlé de la commission merheb
s'amène vous avez une seule des mesures
mises en oeuvre il ya la deuxième sur
dont a parlé marie noëlle mais moi je
voulais savoir quel autre proposition de
la commission rebsamen vous comptez
mettre en place en particulier sur la
question de la libération du foncier
vient daniel salmon suite sylviane noël
ces personnages présidente madame la
ministre j'étais la convention régionale
action logement bretagne vendredi et les
échanges portaient vraiment sur la
pression immobilière surtout en zone en
zone littorale qui est très intense et
d'une manière très centré transpartisane
les questions étaient sur comment
remettre dans le marché du logement les
logements vacants comment agir sur herbe
yembi comment faire en sorte que de
limiter les maisons qui ne sont ouvertes
que deux mois dans l'année donc voilà ça
ce sont vraiment des questions qui sont
venus mais d'une manière complètement
transparente izan parce qu'il est
aujourd'hui une demande vraiment des
habitants à l'année
concernant la rénovation
énergétique tout autre sujet sur 435
milles dossiers qui ont été déposés dans
le cadre de ma prime rénove seulement
moins de 1200 porte sur une rénovation
globale
comment faire en sorte qu'on ne soit pas
simplement sur des changements de
chaudière mais vraiment sur des actions
qu'ils nous fassent aller vers des
bâtiments basse consommation
voilà merci
merci daniel sylviane noël il n'y a plus
d'autres demandes de prise de parole si
bien merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre je souhaitais vous
interroger sur le dispositif ma prime
rénove également qui connaissent le
terrain de nombreux dysfonctionnements
en retard 2 en raison de retards de
payement important autant du côté
des artisans qui ont parfois avancé les
stocks de marchandises important ce qui
met en danger leur trésorerie que du
côté des particuliers qui sont amenés
également avancer des sommes importantes
car les dossiers sont kafkaïen c'était
donc savoir ce qu'il en était réellement
et quelles solutions comptez-vous mettre
en oeuvre pour remédier à ces
difficultés pour commencer à répondre à
marie noëlle lienemann oui la d'action
logement à l'accession sociale à la
propriété de marche bien puisque de sa
part dans celle à
4800 dossiers ont déjà été déposés 2700
sont des dossiers complets en
instruction pour l'instant action
logement à une cible à 20000 mais
maintenant que on est dans un
partenariat je pense aux opérationnels
et efficaces avec action logement pour
moi on peut vraiment continuer à voir la
discussion avec eux si ces primes
partent rapidement s'il est envisageable
de prolonger et d'avoir un volume de
primes plus élevées et après je pense
que ça n'empêche pas d'avoir une
réflexion et à sur le sujet vous savez
que la question du prêt à taux zéro et
est aussi posée à la question de savoir
s'il fallait le laisser sous forme de
prêt à taux zéro avec des prêts avec des
taux d'intérêt qui sont évidemment bas
c'est qui veut dire que toutes choses
égales par ailleurs ça coûte moins cher
à l'état de basse et en prêt à taux zéro
quand les taux sont à 1% que quand il
était à 7 et que du coup on pourrait
imaginer transformé ça imprime nous
n'avons pas fait cette transformation
pour l'instant nous avons prolongé le
tout arrosé le prêt à taux zéro dans
l'esprit il indiqué tout à l'heure c'est
à dire donner de la visibilité à tous
les acteurs mais je pense que c'est
aussi un sujet de savoir si c'est le bon
outil tel quel après les banques les
financeurs les réseaux les agences
immobilières etc ils sont finalement
assez attachés parce que c'est un outil
connu et banquiers et qui du data
manière soutien quand même les dossiers
donc il n'y a pas d'urgence à le
modifier mais en tout cas pense qu'on
peut travailler dans les deux directions
continue à travailler avec action
logement et voir s'il est possible
d'aller plus loin
sur votre question sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés
les eaux et fès en fonction de leur
statut on a commencé l'analyse mais on
est en pleine discussion avec bercy là
dessus donc j'ai pas de réponse très
précis vous à vous apporter
donc je vais pas pouvoir aller tellement
plus loin aujourd'hui on a bien commencé
à regarder c'est juste un sujet qui est
pas totalement consensuelle en
interministériel à ce stade mais non
mais les choses peuvent toujours
s'arranger c'est vous qui vous les
femmes à damas voilà c'est ça exactement
vous avez tout compris sur les contrats
locaux
on a annoncé pour l'instant des contrats
de relance du logement avec les communes
en face et soit avec les communes soit
avec les intercommunalités soit un un
volet du crt e contrat de relancer
transition écologique que soient des
contrats tout seul donc une circulaire
aux préfets et parti a pas longtemps le
premier ministre en a parlé aux préfets
dans une réunion de préfets ya trois
semaines elle circulaire aux préfets
partie dans la foulée l'objectif est
d'en signer dès la fin de cette année
pour remobiliser la deuxième partie de
l' enveloppe de l'aide à la relance de
la construction durable dans un système
plus contractualisés après moi je pense
que ces outils seront utiles je suis
assez convaincu que dans l'état actuel
du droit c'est la contractualisation
entre l'état et le bloc communal qui
permettra de développer l'offre de
logement l'état à une partie des leviers
avec un peu de fiscale est un peu de
régulation in fine et les permis de
construire sont sous la responsabilité
des communes il du coup c'est dans une
contractualisation dans laquelle on peut
faire masse des différents dispositifs
et se mettre d'accord sur une
orientation générale et ensuite mettre
en cohérence l'adaptation des
trajectoires sru l'éventuelle discussion
sur la manière dont on dont on fait les
attributions de logements sociaux au
fait ya un certain nombre de sujets
qu'on peut mettre dans une discussion
commune si on est sûr qu on poursuit les
mêmes objectifs à savoir répondre aux
besoins de logement à l'échelle de la
commune ou l'intercommunalité pour moi
je suis convaincu qu'il faut qu'on
installe une contractualisation
logement au sens large
on a beaucoup de briques de cette
contractualisation mais en fait on l'a
pas vraiment globalisé et du coup on
l'apprend dispositif phare dispositif
alors que in fine et ce sera plus
intéressant de se poser la question
quels sont les besoins et probablement
qu'on a besoin des deux niveaux la
commune et l'intercommunalité
l'intercommunalité parce que c'est quand
même l'échelle à laquelle cs ça a quand
même du sens et la commune parce qu'il
finesse et elle qui est compétente
donc on commence avec les contrats de
relance du logement mais l'idée c'est
probablement d'essayer de dalé un petit
peu plus loin sur la surcompensation les
discussions techniques sont en cours de
façon je crois approfondie et apaisé on
le fait dans le bon sens on discute de
la méthode avant de revenir devant le ca
de l'anc holtz la question de
l'accession sociale et de la vente du
parc a été clairement très clairement
identifiés dans les discussions donc là
j'irai pas plus loin dans la technique
mais c'est un point qu'on a bien joué
sur les apl
ce que disait madame artigalas c'est que
la réforme technique on a fini par la
faire on en a reculé deux fois
la bascule informatique a eu lieu qu'il
y avait un certain nombre de bugs j'en
profite pour saluer les agents des caf
parce que ils ont été réactifs le
système est quand même à peu près rodé
maintenant donc on s'est versé les apl
sens en termes de droit et encore une
chance encore heureux dans le nouveau
système après c'était effectivement une
réforme quand vous prenez les dernières
ressources connues et comme les
dernières ressources connues sont plus
élevés que les ressources d'avancé
forcément une réforme qui paraît le même
fait des économies et en à chiffre est à
peu près 1,1 milliard d'euros les
économies liées à cette réforme on a
maintenant une dépense appelant base qui
est stable qui à 15 7 milliards c'est la
dépense prévue en 2021 c'est aussi la
dépense prévue en 2022 donc on sait
maintenant que les notes dépenses apl de
base est par ailleurs on était tous très
inquiets sur une explosion éventuelle de
la pauvreté une perte très forte de
revenus etc au moment du début de la
crise qu vide l'insee a sorti des
chiffres sur la pauvreté que vous
connaissez qui dit que la pauvreté a
légèrement reculé en tout cas au sens
statistique du terme on a pas eu
d'explosion d'impayés de loyers bas
c'est quand même ce que l'insee dit
après on peut on peut dire c'est pour ça
que je suis prudente en disant au sens
statistique du terme ça veut pas dire
que on vit bien quand on est juste au
dessus du seuil de pauvreté aux oies 60%
du revenu médian mais on vous n'auriez
pas forcément dit la même chose si
lindsay avait augmenté avait constaté
une augmentation significative du taux
de pauvreté et liedson n'a pas constaté
donc du coup la dépense apl qui aurait
pu exploser si les revenus avaient été
plus bas puisque par définition avec des
revenus plus bas vous aviez plus de
bénéficiaires de prestations sous
conditions de ressources est maintenant
stabilisé à 15 milliards 7 sur les
agréments de logements sociaux
on a continué à faire un effort qui
n'est pas incompatible avec la mixité
sociale je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit
vigilant sur notre capacité y compris
les capacités des communes à accueillir
des populations très fragilisés dans des
conditions qui font que ça n'en font ce
pas la totalité des communes elles-mêmes
et des populations qui y vivent déjà
d'où la volonté de mixité sociale mais
c'est ce qu'on fait sur la
reconstitution de l'offre en rue fait
dire je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
depuis longtemps sur le fait que
maintenant quand on reconstitue quand on
détruit dans les quartiers de la
politique de la ville pour des raisons
de 2,2 de vétusté du bâti des logements
sociaux et qu'on les reconstituent on
essaye de par reconstituer l'offre de
logements sociaux exactement dans le
coeur des quartiers la politique de la
ville mais d'essayer d'éteindre un peu
de proposer aussi une forme de mixité
sociale qui permet d'avoir un vivre
ensemble de bonne qualité un peu partout
ça n'empêchera tout s'est très fortement
logement social et c'est ce qu'on fait
avec l'objectif de 250 milles et avec la
discussion de la loi sru
dans les conditions qu'on a indiqué sur
la libération du foncier oui je pense
que c'est vraiment le sujet qui est
devant nous maintenant c'est le foncier
c'est vraiment un sujet compliqué
comment est-ce qu'on comment est ce
qu'on trouve les outils pour lutter
contre
la spéculation est l'augmentation
inexorable du prix du foncier alors il
ya le foncier public son tout premier
ministre a sollicité
la direction immobilier l'état les
administrations les établissements
publics de l'état pour essayer de
libérer du foncier et la question
d'éviter nous mêmes de faire des
enchères sur du foncier public qui est
un sujet comme maintenant on prend à
bras le corps prévenait d'ailleurs
annoncé que dans les 68 quartier de
gares d'île de france hier il demandait
aux services de l'état et aux
établissements publics grand paris
aménagement et autres de renoncer à
toute méthode de mise aux enchères des
fonciers plus bout pour éviter ce genre
de choses on a un inventaire du foncier
public on va réaménager on retravaille
les sujets de décote et après je pense
qu'on a devant nous une question plus
globale de savoir quel type de
régulation du foncier pack public mais
du foncier tout court alors bien sûr les
au fsl démembrement de propriété une
manière d'y répondre c'est pas
majoritaires sur le marché ça ne sera
pas mais je reconnais avec vous colle au
delà du foncier public mais aussi la
question du foncier des collectivités
parce qu'il ya le foncier de l'état puis
associé des collectivités on a une
question france y est plus générale je
suis en retard c'est ça danse ça va
encore
sur la pression immobilière dans les
zones notamment littorales oui c'est un
sujet qui monte
là dedans il ya des choses qui sont un
peu de nature différente sur les
logements vacants on a relancé un plan
de mobilisation des logements vacants
on peut peut-être regarder comment
mobiliser mieux aussi la taxe sur les
logements vacants on est prêt à y
retravailler et par ailleurs je vous
parlais de le louer abordables tout à
l'heure parce que je pense que c'est un
dispositif si on arrive à le faire
connaître suffisamment bien pourrait
motiver des propriétaires à remettre sur
le marché des logements vacants sur
herbe yembi on a quand même beaucoup
resserrer la réglementation on a pris
les trois décrets qui étaient en attente
depuis un certain temps qui permette aux
communes qui le souhaitent d'exiger de
la compensation face non seulement de de
surveiller les 120 jours maximum mais ce
n'est pas la partie la plus compliquée
mais surtout d'exiger de la compensation
on les opérateurs qui sont des
opérateurs professionnels lorsqu'ils eux
ce qu'ils transforment un logement
airbnb compensée par d'autres logements
mis en location pour des rues famille et
après sur les résidences secondaires
ouverte deux mois par an là ça devient
un sujet plus délicat savoir
comment enfin comment est ce qu'on
trouve la bonne articulation entre
la résidence secondaire avec d'ailleurs
des gens qui vont être de plus en plus
50% 50% et la résidence principale parce
que ça nous ramène plus tôt au sujet du
développement de l'offre mais donc quand
je mettrai pas totalement sur le même
plan les logements vacants les airbnb et
les résidences secondaires qui sont des
problématiques un peu différente sur ma
prime rénove
d'abord on a des chiffres sur les
économies d'énergie ma prime rénove du
premier sms 2021 qui est le premier
moment où ma prime rénove a été ouvert à
tous les français puisque en 2020
c'était moitié ma prime run-off moitié
c'est idiot et donc si on compare les
économies d'énergie de ma prime rénove
au premier semestre 2021 par rapport aux
ces ide du premier semestre 2010 9 parce
que 2020 si une année pas très
comparables ont fait deux fois mieux en
économies d'énergie avec ma prime rénove
et quatre fois mieux en baisse
d'émissions de co2 donc ma prime rénove
ça marche mieux en économie d'énergie et
en économie de co2 que le seuil était de
toutes choses égales par ailleurs ça
n'empêche pas que on a en des dossiers
qui sont plutôt des dossiers mono geste
et que notre objectif avec mon
accompagnateur rénove au 1er janvier
2022 et surtout 1er janvier 2023 c'est
d'accompagner les ménages vers de la
rénovation plus globale ou plus complète
1er janvier 2022 on met en place mon
accompagnateur reynolds de façon
volontaire optionnel au 1er janvier 2023
on dit que c'est obligatoire de passer
par mon accompagnateur rénove avec un
montant soit travaux soient des dons l'a
pas encore arbitré on a des craintes à
produire qui sera mis en consultation
j'espère rapidement voilà pour cette
audition de la ministre du logement
emmanuelle wargon qui a défendu devant
les sénateurs la réforme des apl des
allocations logement cette réforme
prévoit de calculer désormais à la
location en fonction du revenu actuel du
bénéficiaire et plus en fonction du
revenu des années précédentes selon la
ministre cette réforme des apl a permis
à l'état d'économiser 1,1 milliard
d'euros c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi continu à suivre
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
sur notre site internet publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
sur public sénat
me